let's talk about the number one most common sign
of low stomach acid indigestion indigestion what
is that indigestion is a sensation where the
food is kind of stuck in your stomach it's not
moving properly you feel full bloated you've got
an upset stomach some heartburn you feel nauseous
might be belching so that's what indigestion
is and of course there are other symptoms of
low stomach acid too especially getting gas and
just general bloating now if you look this up
medically it'll say that 70 percent of the time there's
no cause okay there's no cause you just have it
it could be coming from stress anxiety or gerd
which doesn't make sense to me because gerd is
a symptom and that's where you have acid splashing
up so what they're saying is acid that splashes up
will cause indigestion so one symptom causes
something else i guess it could be related but
as far as a root cause i don't buy that but i can
see stress being one big cause for sure and there
are many other causes as well i've done videos on
them i'll put a link down below the medical term
for low stomach acid is called hypochlorhydria and
there's another condition where you don't have any
acid in your stomach that's called a chlorhydria
and you can check out more information on that but
this topic is very important simply because as you
age you lose your stomach acid and so many people
just don't have enough acid in the stomach anymore
and they're getting these symptoms and i don't
even know what's behind it and so they start
taking antacids they take medication for this
and now they go from bad to worse because now it's
going to take out that last drop that they needed
and now they don't have very much acid at all
so they start developing hay fever allergies and
sinus issues and all sorts of problems normally
the ph of hydrochloric acid should be between
0.8 to 1.5 and it can even go up to 3. so it's
between 0.8 0.823 which is extremely acid and it's
a combination of this acid and this enzyme pepsin
which by the way is activated by this acid to help
you digest things so pepsin is a very strong
enzyme to help you digest protein what prevents
the acid and this powerful protein enzyme from
digesting the inside of your stomach is a very
thick mucous layer and so when this layer becomes
destroyed that can come from a lack of zinc it
could come from several things then you start
developing ulcers gastritis and issues like that
so we need this layer of protection your body
actually makes two liters of hydrochloric acid
every single day and guess what you need to to
make it you need chlorides from salt you also need
potassium you need vitamin c and several other
things like zinc now the purpose of hydrochloric
acid is to take the protein that you just ate
let's say you ate some meat which has protein
and collagen and all sorts of things and turn that
into amino acids to break it down into the small
particles so if you don't have enough acid you'll
get incomplete protein digestion also number two
it helps you kill microbes bacteria fungus yeast
and viruses without that acid these microbes can
invade the body and go down there and create all
sorts of damage and something called sibo and they
can invade your gut and create problems so it's a
defense mechanism viruses and bacteria do not like
acid number three they help you absorb minerals
a lot of times the minerals are locked up with
proteins for example if you ask someone what what
food is high in iron you would say red meat right
or when you talk about calcium dairy that comes
with a protein right cobalt is part of vitamin
b12 which is actually in red meat and organ meats
zinc is in shellfish seafood and red meat as well
and also magnesium is in meat as well and
vegetables however if you don't have enough
acid you can't separate out the mineral from
this protein structure not to mention you're
going to have a difficult time absorbing and
assimilating these minerals right here and
so there's a very simple simple solution if you
don't have an ulcer or if you don't have gastritis
it's simply to take some betaine hydrochloride you
can get this as a supplement i'll put a link down
below for more information on this but betaine
hydrochloride is a very simple safe solution
you would want to take something like three
or four or even five with right before you eat
and you'll start feeling a lot less indigestion
pretty quick but it might take some time you
might have to do that for several weeks but
you'll find though you'll have less gas less
bloating less fullness and you'll get more
complete digestion with this and you're going
to start to feel better because you'll start to
assimilate these minerals right here now if you
have gastritis or an ulcer or you feel worse when
you take this then you need to watch my video on
what to do with an ulcer or gastritis before
you go if you have a question about a product or
you're new to keto and you want to know
how to begin keto or you're on keto and
you need a debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to help you
this is just for the people in the us hopefully in
the future we'll be able to answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below
so you can call and get some help